hello everyone I'm a guest commentator
on this channel and I'm simply
presenting some information that was
presented to me by the owner of this
channel who had some great content up on
secondary gunning for the tanks
unfortunately he didn't have anyone to
voice it over for him so here I am
let's start with an introduction as the
secondary gunner your main job really
isn't to kill the enemies the driver
will generally do that faster and more
efficiently your main job is simply to
insure the vehicles continued survival
so the driver can continue to destroy
the enemy
repairs communication and alertness are
very important traits for a secondary
gunner to have you play four points
levels or kills secondary gunning is
probably not for you you are first and
foremost a support position
you should be vigilant you should be
looking for enemies wherever the driver
isn't looking
there's a reason you have the ability to
look higher and turn faster than the
driver
people will come from all directions
they will leave in parachute down from
above to see for you and to facilitate
this there's a friendly little icon at
the bottom of your screen this is the
HUD showing where the tank driver is
looking and where you are looking the
long hand is where the drivers camera is
pointing and the short hand is where
your camera is pointing regularly do
quick checks of the mini-map and of your
surroundings even if you currently do
have valid targets to shoot perhaps
you're shooting at a target at a far
distance and the more immediate threat
is a c4 runner that's coming up behind
you
anywhere you or the driver isn't looking
is a blind spot and is a potential
vector for attack which means that you
shouldn't focus for too long in one
direction and you shouldn't get complete
as you get experience you'll know when
you can fire away heedlessly and when
you should be vigilant and cautious
using the third-person view in normal
core can be very useful for checking
close quarters threats
use your spot function constantly to
double-check every portion of dark
corner for threats
and don't forget to check the road for
mines
because of mines and slabs be highly
suspicious of commonly mined areas like
choke points and flags
besides spamming the spot function
whenever you're on the move proximity
scan auto spots explosives close to you
however that won't be good enough if
you're driving fast
manually spotting them with thermal or
irnv optics which makes them very bright
it makes it easier for you to pick out
mines from further away
any explosive weapon will blow out the
slams and mines any gun including the
gunner mg can blow the slams but only
explosives and certain weapons like
revolvers and shotgun slugs can blow up
80 mines
let's continue with some basics on the
50 Cal or the gunner machine gun as a
rule of thumb for new Gunners you should
avoid firing at things that you probably
can't kill or isn't a threat to your
tanks longevity firing puts you on the
mini-map so avoid it whenever the driver
is repositioning or he's flanking or if
he's out of sight of the enemy at all
and especially when he's attempting a
hasty retreat
positioning is a very important part to
polymer combat so don't mess it up for
your driver by exposing his location to
the enemy of
course it's not always clear-cut women
is clear to shoot and when it isn't
sometimes it makes perfect sense to
shoot at helicopters this will be
discussed further in part 2 for
smaller targets longer ranges make sure
to burst your gun and reset your spread
listen for when it starts to overheat
and pick your targets but the most part
you really should be shooting an
infantry since that's the only target
you can consistently kill if the enemy
can hurt you more than you can hurt him
like choppers consider it repairing
instead there really isn't a hard and
fast rule of knowing when to repair it
comes down to how much damage you can
prevent with the 50 Cal or what you can
repair away if your driver wants to
reposition probably you should
preemptively stop the attack with the 50
Cal ng if you can't do that you might
consider repairing it a good example of
this is getting attacked by aircraft
when there is no cover and many times
it's better to repair between scrapes
than returning fire repairing greatest
attribute is that is reliable you can
negate the cooled of the repair tool by
quickly pausing every eight seconds
upper preparing does leave you unable to
scan the area and limits their drivers
movements because you're slow yeah you
know it's kind of hard to keep up with a
tank do know that you do have control
where you dismount from the vehicle
whatever side the 50 Cal is pointing at
is the side that you like sit on
and you can use this trick to zip
quickly from one side of the vehicle to
the other
use your own vehicle to cover yourself
and keep moving so that you won't be as
easy to kill remember before you hop
back into your vehicle switch to
something lethal like a weapon you don't
really want to have your a pair tool in
hand when you encounter c4 runners
the 50 Cal cannot shoot targets that are
too closer to high whenever an enemy is
inside or approaching minimum range is
probably going to plant c4 and slams on
you dismount immediately and kill them
on foot
a
gunner incendiary just kills too slowly
to be a reliable counter
make sure the enemy doesn't leave any
slams behind they live forever and can
trigger on movement
now that we've covered that let's move
on to one of the most infamous foes
whenever you see a dirtbike quad bike or
buggy assume that is laced with c4 or
Slams and keep track of it smart jihad
jeeps will flank wide come in from
unlikely directions and use cover and
elevation to their advantage so expect
the unexpected
a lack of situational awareness means
instant death for you and your driver
your driver has the best hope of
stopping a jihad but he may not always
react in time and the 50 Cal doesn't do
enough damage to take out a suicide
vehicle reliably instead whenever a jeep
is closing in a spot it yelling your
drivers either get out of your vehicle
as the Jeep approaches and hand it with
a rocket launcher
got it
it's okay
got it suicide vehicles alone are a
decent reason for boarding vehicles with
your launch around so it's the first
weapon in your hand when you step out
oftentimes engineers will fight you from
places where it is difficult or risky
for you or your driver to retaliate when
you find someone hiding in one of those
places consider rooting them out on foot
rooting out works best when you can take
out enemies quickly while they're still
focusing on your vehicle
here again a powerful close-range weapon
such as a PDW or carbine will serve you
quite well we'll discuss this and other
loadout options in part 2 of this guide
this is all for part one I hope you
enjoyed and stay tuned for part two